here today I'm going to talk a little
bit about Canada and some recent
articles in the newspaper that have to
do with immigrant language learning a
while ago the Canadian government
announced that all immigrants would have
to reach level four on the Canadian
language benchmarks which is about a a
two on the European framework sort of
like an advanced beginner level in order
to immigrate to Canada and that even
landed immigrants would have to reach
that level in order to acquire
citizenship people over the age of 55
would be exempt this of course created a
great fawful in the immigrant services
industry leading I would say leading but
a Chinese politician wrote in the
newspaper that this was racist I gather
that leaders of the sort of Chinese
ethnic organizations here were against
this idea it was considered unfair and
so forth so that was one of it then
there was an article in the Toronto Star
reporting on a study that was done by an
institute in Montreal very reputable
Institute where they had traced
immigrants whose native languages
Mandarin and compared them to immigrants
whose native language was either Russian
or Ukrainian and they found that the
Mandarin speaking group made relatively
little or made no essentially no
progress in their comprehension
pronunciation and ability to use English
over a period of seven years so they
followed however many 30 or 40
immigrants and they found that the
essentially they made no progress
whatever level in the language they
arrived with essentially that's what
they had after seven years which is more
or less what I found with the people
that I've met in the Chinese immigrant
community if they arrived speaking
English they maintain it although one
lady said she spoke more English in Hong
Kong than she does in Vancouver
but normally they maintain it but they
don't improve whereas the Russian
Ukrainian Slovak language speaking
immigrants improved the Chinese group
were less likely to have more than a
10-minute conversation with a Canadian
they were less knowledgeable about
Canadian events and so forth so you take
these two together China is well perhaps
or has been for the last 10 years the
largest source country of immigrants to
Canada so the first question is you know
should immigrants be required to learn
English well I think they should because
citizenship is really all about
membership in a society you can't be
separate from the society because you're
you're involved you're pay taxes you're
part of the medical system the school
system you're part of that society you
live beside other people you work with
other people you you can't just be
isolated in your own language community
I mean you can but from the point of
view of the receiving community the
existing society here that's probably
not considered very desirable you know
if I listen to what Canadians have to
say like my teammates in the old-timers
hockey you know they say one of them
said he was at a citizenship swearing-in
ceremony and there were people there who
couldn't speak English and he was
appalled that we would give citizenship
to someone who can't speak English and
so surely the existing members of
society should have some say in who they
want to accept as new citizens and I am
sure that a requirement to speak one or
one of the two national languages would
be quite high so I think that's a
legitimate I request unfortunately the
level the government has asked for is
extremely low you will not be able to
work with a beginner level in English
but I guess it's better than nothing but
even at that there's this great
resistance to it
at the other end of the spectrum you
have this study of group of I think 30
or so and I'll post the link Mandarin
speakers who'll essentially made no
progress we spend a fortune here on
language instruction for immigrants and
immigrants may spend some money of their
own they certainly spend their time some
time the time they spend in class and
the Mandarin speaking group doesn't
improve why is that well in obviously
the Mandarin speakers have certain
disadvantages when learning English they
don't have as much common vocabulary the
Slavic language speakers have almost
Latin and Greek origin words this the
language systems are more similar
however is someone who has learned Asian
languages I don't consider that to be an
insurmountable problem rather the
biggest issue is that the Slavic
speakers are more motivated to find out
about the new society that they have
moved to even though they maintain
contact with the you know in many cases
with the Russian speaking or Ukrainian
speaking or I don't know what they just
said Slavic maybe our Croatian speaking
community but they integrate more
they're more motivated to connect with
and make friends with other members of
this new society that they moved into
whereas the motivation for this amongst
matter speakers is not very strong and
that's been my observation you do meet
exceptions I met people who came here
and went to work selling door-to-door
when they have a very strong accent and
lo and behold within a few years they
were speaking flawless English so
there's no reason why a Chinese person
if so motivated would also not be able
to improve their English but it's
absolutely astounding this is a very
serious study after seven years there's
no significant progress in their level
of English that can only mean to me that
they're not motivated to improve I am
thoroughly convinced that anyone who is
motivated to improve who takes
responsibility for their own learning
will improve but there again I think the
Mandarin speaking group is more inclined
to believe that a teacher has to teach
them they have to go to school and that
there's nothing they can do
their own and they don't sort of relate
the fact that they watched nothing but
mandarin-speaking television programs in
the evening to the fact that they can't
speak English very well so you know and
what if I was think myself maybe the
government should say you know if the
immigrant achieves achieves level four
on the Canadian language benchmark
system I might add that I think of all
the different systems for you know
giving people levels in a language the
Canadian language benchmark system is
undoubtedly the worst overly complicated
you can't understand what it's trying to
say half the time fine shades up you
know level three you can ask for the
bathroom but you can't order a beer
level four you can ask for the bathroom
but you can't do something else
I mean it's extremely complex and I
think quite silly but that's the system
we have here but if they said okay if
you achieve level 4 you get citizenship
if you achieve level 8 you get $10,000 I
think a lot of people would learn in
other words it's all about motivation
you have to figure out how to motivate
people
the Chinese group have such a large
group of people who speak the same
language here they don't feel
tremendously motivated they quickly sort
of slop themselves into a low paid job
working for Chinese people I might add
that any Chinese employer is extremely
unlikely to hire anybody but another
Chinese person whereas in the mainstream
economy in fact you do see a lot of
people including Chinese people who work
within the mainstream economy so there's
this tremendous desire to kind of stay
amongst themselves which inhibits
language learning now you know it gets
back to the subject to I just to finish
off with this whole business of the
university education I did up a video
about the students striking in Quebec
and I think they're of course quite
silly they're saying you know education
should be free when a person is not
education at all the issue is the ticket
they want their diploma to be free
because most of those students
studying the humanities might be
studying language for that matter and
just as with the example of the
immigrants and their language learning
if you said ok here is an institution or
the number of Institute's that will
issue diplomas and they will test for a
month it doesn't matter they test your
ability to write to express yourself to
understand to whatever in history
sociology whatever it might be and once
a year you have to go and get tested but
where your study is up to you if
students have to pay the equivalent of
twenty thousand dollars a year which is
what it costs to go to one of our
universities as they are now established
the student pays three thousand three
hundred didn't come back five thousand
in most provinces the students in Quebec
are being asked to pay a little more but
it's still 15 to 20 percent of the true
cost but if anyone had to pay the true
cost of a university education in order
to get that education or could go and
study on their own wherever they wanted
but they could get the diploma by going
to the diploma diploma granting
institution so they needn't spend their
time and money at a university they can
do it online they can do it in libraries
they can organize themselves however
they want I think that the number of
people going to university would decline
tremendously even though people like to
say you know it's very important you
it's very stimulating something that
yeah but not for twenty thousand dollars
a year so here again just as with the
language learning if you say okay what
you want is a diploma which you think is
gonna help you get a better job
fine even if the government paid for the
testing but though where you go to get
the education is entirely up to you you
would find that a lot of people would
get themselves educated pretty quickly
just as well and would get their
diplomas similarly the language learn if
you told those immigrants from China
that you know if they achieve whatever
level in English they make twenty
thousand dollars which you know I don't
know what it costs
to educate those immigrants but I I read
summaries like two or three thousand
dollars a year and we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of immigrants we
spend I'm sure we have spent billions of
dollars so it's far better far more
economical to say to the immigrants if
you achieve level X you get twenty
thousand dollars okay now you go and
educate yourself wherever you want if
you want to go to school with that
that's fine but they at the end the end
result is twenty thousand dollars so you
pay for the result you don't pay for
people to attend school such has been
the case with these Mandarin speaking
immigrants who have been studying
English and paid for by the government
and who make no progress you pay for the
result if you achieve the result you get
this money so it's your risk if you
don't think you're gonna get there you
won't spend the money fine but then the
results won't be very different from
what they are now because right now
according to this study they don't
improve anyway so yeah well I kind of
meandered around a few topics and I'm
sure I'll get a fair amount of negative
comment as usual but I look forward to
your opinions thank you for listening